the jurogan experience
so what was the motivation to build this
v8 tesla
that's a good question so
i let's get pull up a video of uh rich's
uh youtube channel tesla got a um as i
was building you know different teslas
over the years a lot of the
i guess the fanboys got to me after a
while i mean have you have you been
around like tesla fanatics like ultra
fanatics that are just i try to avoid
all fanatics yes
in every single area every genre yes
whatsoever it's just they're too crazy
it's a bit much so
what started happening over time was
tesla kind of pulled the reins in on
ordering parts for car if i want to
order like a battery or a motor a
battery a motor charger i can't do those
things like those are restricted parts
you can't do that so what that tells me
is that the product that i bought the
product i spent all this money on
i can't i don't really own it right
because they're in control of the parts
for it like an iphone correct yes
exactly like iphone so i said to myself
you know what
oh that's a funny clip that's what i
actually ran out of gas there
got a figure
out of gas and that's actually an
electric tesla bringing me gas that's a
different story but um
what ended up happening was
it
over time it got worse and worse over
time it's like well well what's the
what's the vin number to this car oh we
don't we don't believe in selling these
parts this this isn't going to work that
car is a salvage car you can't do it and
i said myself you know what what um
what can i do to this vehicle
to make it so that i can get parts easy
and it's easy to service and i have full
control over it i said you know what i'm
a chevy fanboy i'm going to throw an ls
in there throwing an ls in there that
allows me to get parts literally off the
shelf from autozone for tesla if i tell
us a break let's just say you're in your
plaid right now right and you break down
the side of the road and the toaster
driver says what am i going to bring you
you're going to say autozone or advanced
auto parts or pet boys no there isn't a
single part sold for those cars there if
i break down the v8 tesla you pull me
anywhere i could get
pistons rods you name it lifters valves
for that car literally anywhere and i
have full control over it how did you
make the v8 engine interface with the
tesla dashboard that's a great question
so
all cars have what's known as an
accessory mode right the drive rails
aren't on and it's the engine isn't on
but the accessories are on you're going
to record like the screen turns on but
the engine isn't on right so the tesla
effectively believes it's an accessory
mode right now all the windows work
the headlights work the turn signals
work everything works it's just that the
last button to turn on the drive rails
and actually start the car that's no
longer there and that's what the v8
engine takes over so imagine imagining
um you have your
i don't know you have your porsche right
your gt3
you get in that car you're sitting it
right now and you do everything but turn
the engine over
all the accessories work the lights work
the radio works everything works except
for that last phase to turn the fuel
pump on set the spark plugs on to turn
the engine over so the tesla just thinks
it's on and idle but not ready to drive
really yeah and how did you rig that so
the v8 so basically any tesla will do
that you pull tesla out of a junkyard
you could get in it sit in it make sure
it's getting power and you can at least
get to that step now the way the v8
takes over is v8s are probably the it's
the dumbest engine alive you you give it
you give it a battery to start it over
and you give it fuel it's going to run
so there's a separate control system for
the engine itself so we have a haltech
system that communicates with that so
there's actually two separate systems
that control the car and if one of those
systems dies the car will still function
if the tesla screen dies all of a sudden
the tesla says you know what i had
enough of this that v8 it'll still turn
on and i could still go wherever i want
you just won't have a speedometer and
you want to have a fuel gauge well
actually i will because the the separate
system the hall tech system controls the
the gas engine still oh so there's two
independent systems that work separate
of each other so the separate system
what what kind of dashboard are you
looking at are you looking at the same
dashboard that a regular tesla has the
same so that speedometer still works too
because it goes by the wheel speed
sensors that speedometer still works the
navigation works the bluetooth works the
car works really if you were to sit in
that car right now
besides the the six-speed shifter you
wouldn't be able to tell anything
special about it
so you have a six-speed manual in there
six-speed manual shifter yeah if you see
it right there in that video right there
to the back it up a little bit you call
it ice-t i see yeah
yeah i like it so there's a shift there
right in the middle
and it's a six speed it's sequentially
shifted you tap it forward and tap it
back to go oh okay
that's like a race car that's it right
there yep what is that second gear to
the left of it uh that's the engage uh
reverse oh so you pull back to go in
reverse wow yeah so that's the only way
you could tell i mean everything else
works on the screen like the door
indicator buttons work the sunroof works
literally everything works in that car
how hard was this to do
um it took a team of us it was we have a
joshua our our fabricator we had to
literally cut the car in half
really to form the transmission tunnel
because teslas are teslas are one of the
few cars which are great because they
were designed as evs only right right
some companies will take a gas car and
then throw an electric drivetrain in it
and call it a day tussles were designed
from the ground up to be electric
vehicles what the model s was so the
floor is completely flat
if for rear wheel drive cars you have a
drive shaft that goes from the front to
the back
well we couldn't put that there because
the floor is flat we have to cut the car
in half
install the engine and then build a
transmission tunnel over that drive
shaft from the front all the way back
also a transmission tunnel as well whoa
because there's the transmission you
know that sticks out like so this is all
fabricated all fabrication all
i mean
countless hours have gone into that so
how long from the time you had this idea
to the actual starting and driving about
two years
wow so
crazy
you know how it is like you you the
planning stages are like yeah i'm gonna
do this right yeah i'm gonna do it i
should do it how much is that nah i'm
not gonna do it then you i was
contemplating for a while and then i
said you know what i gotta commit to
this let's start doing this
uh hooked up with joshua he's like hey
listen he actually um fun fact so
he was watching one of the videos and
he's just like hey like you know if you
need help with fabrication stuff let me
know
um he used to build like nascar's like
two chassis okay he says i could do
stuff never seen his work before i took
that v8 tesla
dropped it off at his house and i said i
trust you on this one
and then that was it the rest was
history so i would we would go there
shoot video
the first start video was there and we
just worked on it until the end and then
it's running and driving so when you cut
it in half
do you have to do something to ensure
this the rigidity structure yeah there's
there's bracing and reinforcements all
over the car so is it much heavier than
the original car it's about 1200 pounds
light in the original car really yes
because the electric engine in the
battery is missing if you think about it
the uh the average battery weight of a
tesla is well over a thousand pounds
eleven hundred pounds in some cases that
makes sense there was a rear motor that
uh rear motor subframe that was like
350 pounds 400 pounds then there's a
front motor as well
so the front motor uh after moving all
that weight uh putting an engine in the
transmission and ls is one of the
lightest engines they make with the
drivetrain
we that car went from
4975 pounds to like 3
300 pounds the car weighs next to
nothing now wow comparably speaking 3
000 pounds for a sedan is really light
it's very light and that has the full
interior of the seats it has everything
in there that's like sports car light
yeah it's a light car you'd be amazed at
how much you could remove a shot that's
the tunnel right there that's all the
bracing in the tunnel so we had to build
that so that large that was the first
starboard that was really fun
um
we had to build that tunnel all the
bracing in it so it wouldn't it wouldn't
fall apart
so all that structural tubing going
across to the car doesn't pancake itself
and that's that's that's the work now
when you drive this thing
it obviously wasn't designed to have an
engine in the front and on the
transmission tunnel and all that that
was a fake yoke we put we were going to
put a yoke in it as a joke we ended up
not doing that that's a waste of time i
don't like the yolk no i don't don't
like it as a steering choice it just
sucks when you're trying to park and
pull into places right
um how much did it affect the way the
car handles
the car handle's great we took it on a
race track
so ebay motors actually were responsive
by them they brought us out to a sonoma
raceway
and um we were just doing drone outs and
burnouts around their circle track the
cart it feels you know what it feels
like it feels like uh
almost like a
what's a four-door muscle car a modern
muscle car a charger charger yeah
cadillac c charger srt yes
it's more like a cadillac cts-v wow and
it's just it's light it's fun it'll do a
burnout i would think i was going like
30 miles an hour stomped on it rolling
burn out until like almost 100. the
thing is ridiculous it's really fun yeah
it's really it's a really fun car but
it's that's the thing the biggest debate
was
rich why are you doing this because the
finished product is slower than normal
tesla right i'm like that's fair enough
0-60 is not as fast it's rear-wheel
drive only now it'll spin the tires
until 100 no problem it's um there's no
autopilot that doesn't work anymore but
i'll tell you right now
i took that car to a show
parked it next to
a plaid
the fastest and most amazing car built
right now
people didn't even know there was a
plaid next to me people went crazy over
that car and that's why it was built
because of the novelty because it's the
novelty it's listen
that's the probably the only one that's
going to get built there's no sense in
making a second one because let's be
real the car was expensive to make and
it isn't as fast as a regular tesla it's
just to show what you can do when you
put your mind to it and i'll tell you
man i've had offers to buy that car for
ridiculous amounts of money just because
of what it is you could work on it you
could modify it yourself and it's the
spirit of
car enthusiasts are you going to sell it
never never never you said never i have
a big problem joe i keep
every car i build i keep
every car that's
that represents a memory for me whether
it's friends coming together for a
common cause building something having
all those memories i never sell them
really yeah so the so the v8 test was
one of them because i could see myself
already that car has made so many
memories for as as friends
if i sell that car and i see some
knucklehead driving it down the street
i'll be like that's my car right i want
that why are you having fun in that well
especially the amount of time involved
and thinking that one i get right
about the engineering behind it because
what's it what's it worth to someone
100 150 right 200 i mean no one's gonna
pay 200 for it let's just say 150 for
that car
that's cool but like
now what right i don't have my car back
right and then you're gonna make
something else anyway right true the ls
what is the stock ls out of the box
horsepower last i think about four four
25 or something like that and with a 3
000 pound car that's probably great it's
really fun i think we did a long tube
headers a few other modifications to it
it's like 470 or so right now and then
we're actually putting a supercharger on
it another few months ooh that's going
back to sema but yeah that's the thing
it's like that's why i enjoy about it
like you're plaid right now right let's
just say
you get bored of the power
right
but what do you what do you do to it as
a car enthusiast your porsche gt3 rs you
could do a million different things to
it right it shot works it's been
modified already
your your old muscle cars you could
improve the handling the braking the
power you add whatever you want if
you're on a regular tesla
as an enthusiast i actually got very
bored of mine
because the way you get it is the way
it's going to stay unless you buy a
plaid or you get on your knees and beg
elon to release a software update to
give you 30 more horsepower well there's
a company called unplugged you know
about them of course yeah performance
brand i know them very well yeah so they
will take a tesla and they will jazz it
up and put wider tires and fender flares
and a rear spoiler and right crazy which
is cool but
i want more power right when i step my
foot down i want like my eyes to like go
in the back of my head right and in the
regular tesla you could add a little
suspension stuff you want to feel great
around corners but i want that power i
want one of the stop light i see
everyone in my review mirror so with the
v8 tesla granted no it's it's nothing
crazy now it's fun to drive but you know
what the power of a fully built ls
engine is there's no limit
there's no limit you can keep going you
keep going you can get you know the plat
makes about i think you're probably
putting out maybe 1100 horsepower now on
your planet i think yeah
something like that which is hilarious
which is which is insane the v8 tesla
you could
great you only put in the power of the
rear wheels but you could have 1500 2000
you name it really
ls engine yes infinite power three
thousand power if you want what yeah
what do you have to do to do that you
have to redesign the whole engine
you need to build the whole thing but
yeah three you can get 3000 horsepower
out of an ls engine out of a v8 engine
of course you can yeah oh my god yeah i
didn't had no idea forge block yeah you
have to do literally everything but yeah
i mean you're probably gonna blow up in
your face absolutely it's a ticking time
bomb but it's fun until it blows up but
that's the spirit of car modification
like yeah you drive it you blow it up
you rebuild it and then you do it all
over again
you